Okay so this week
we are going to have our first interview
for this series
and our first ever interview with a politician
on Gary's Economics.
You might remember earlier in the year
I spoke about being approached by Labour
to have politicians on the channel and
we eventually chose not to do it for now
largely because
we need to play a little bit of a game with Labour
for sort of
using what we can to get some influence over them
but also really to be totally honest
one of the reasons we chose not to have politicians
was because I thought most politicians
when they go on TV
when they go on the radio are incredibly boring
they just say their own sort of pat lines
you can tell that
they're just saying what they're supposed to say
and I thought it would be terrible
YouTube basically
but I got contacted by a politician
from another country recently
she reached out to me on Instagram and I was so busy
I forgot to reply and
then last week
I suddenly start getting loads of messages
through loads of channels
from this politician who was saying “listen
I'm an MP in New Zealand
I'm really supportive of wealth taxes
I love the work that you do and I'm here in London
so like please find the time to meet me”.
So I researched a little bit
and I saw that there was
this co leader of the New Zealand Greens
who's been massively supporting wealth
taxes for a long time
I went out and met with her last weekend and she seemed
if I can say honestly like somebody who was not boring
and could talk honestly
and was a little bit thoughtful
about what was happening.
We're here in this space now
where the channel’s growing a lot
and we're starting to figure out,
we'll try and figure out how to influence politicians
how to get involved in politics
how to actually make wealth taxes happen.
So I met with her last weekend and I said
you know what
you seem like a politician who can actually speak
is actually cool
you've flown thousands of miles to be here
we're shooting on Wednesday
why don't you come around and shoot
so this week
our first ever politician on the channel
is gonna be an interview with
Chlöe Swarbrick
co leader of the New Zealand Greens.
Alright so first of all
thank you for flying out here coming such a long way
thank you very much for coming on the channel
it's a pleasure to meet you
some of our viewers won't know who you are
would you be happy to introduce yourself a little bit?
Yeah for sure
My name is Chlöe Swarbrick
I've been involved in politics since I was 23 years old
I guess the long and short of it is that I raged
so hard against the machine
I somehow ended up inside of it.
I'm now 31 years old
and was elected in 2017 as a List MP
so we have something called mixed member proportional
so proportional representation in Aotearoa
New Zealand and then in 2020
I became the MP for Auckland Central
which is the centre of our largest city
which is a city of approximately one and a half,
two million people.
Okay so what made you...
when you first became an MP, is that the right term?
You were, how old were you? 23.
So what made you so
like, keen to get in at such a young age?
I was so angry man
What were you angry about?
hahaha so I had spent
four and a half years on this little radio station
called 95BFM
number one alternative radio station in Auckland
and I've been interviewing these politicians
and community leaders and researchers and academics
and I'd never really understood why
all of the people who had dedicated their lives
to solving these problems
were saying one thing
and the politicians were saying the other
and in 2016 the local body elections were coming up
and I was interviewing the
kind of top four candidates for the Auckland mayoralty
as prescribed by the mainstream media
and I'm a born and bred Aucklander
we've got a lot of problems as a city
but as far as I
was concerned they were our problems
and we had to kind of stay and fight and fix them
and we're experiencing the brain drain
at that time, a lot of my mates were leaving the country
for you know, greener pastures
for lower cost of living
for better job opportunities and god forbid
functional public transport and a decent nightlife
I was complaining about it to my good mate
and producer at the time and she was like
shut up Chloe
go and do something about it
so I googled how to become the mayor of Auckland
I found you had to be over the age of 18
had to pay 200 bucks for administrative fees
and had to have two people nominate you
so I was like, okay cool
I had absolutely no political experience
no idea what the hell I was doing
had never been involved in a political party
I put myself forwards
and just had this really basic thesis
or idea
I guess that god forbid we put ideas on the table and
you know regular people engage with those ideas
and we work together to try and make things better
and obviously I was so young at the time
a lot of people would go at me because of my age
and I'd kind of go, well
very clearly any politician that stands in front of you
and tells you that they know everything
regardless of their age is either lying
to you or completely lacking self awareness
and I'm not sure which of those is worse
so I'm never pretending to have all of the answers
but I'll be crystal clear about what I believe in
and wanna work with the experts
and the people who do know what the answers are
and let's just try and make something of that
you know?
So I wanna talk to you a little bit about politics
because
obviously this is a YouTube channel
primarily about economics and inequality
but in the last like one year
two years we've grown a lot
and it's reached the point where
I feel we need to start
basically trying to influence politics
we've got a new government that's been in for one year
which is Labour, our centre left
party who
you would imagine
should be doing something about inequality
should in theory be open to wealth taxes, but
they haven't really given us much.
So I wanna know a little bit about
your experience in politics and how
if you can sort of give us any advice
how we can influence politics and politicians
because we're at that sort of level
but before we talk about that
I wanna talk a little bit about
New Zealand and the economy in New Zealand
because it's a long way away
most of our, well actually it's quite international now
but most of our viewers are UK,
US, Europe
they might not know that much about New Zealand
you know, other than Lord of the Rings
this kind of stuff so
could you give us like, summarise
what you think are the most
important things we should know about the country
the economy, the economic situation
just a few ideas
how you think it might be similar to what it's like
here in the UK, Europe
the US, how it might be different.
Yeah for sure
so look
first thing I'll say is I love and adore my country
obviously I wouldn't do what I do if I didn't
and I think that we
like so many other countries
have an amazing pool of phenomenal people
who are incredibly hardworking
incredibly creative and incredibly talented
but the problem is, much like here
they are stymied
or blocked from reaching their full potential
because of the way that the economy is rigged
in favour of those at the top.
So to start unpacking that
we had some research
that was commissioned
actually by the former Labour government in 2023
from the Inland Revenue department
our tax department
and what that showed is that at that point in time
the wealthiest 311 households
had a combined wealth of approximately $85 billion
that was more than the bottom
two and a half million New Zealanders combined
bear in mind this is in a country
this is a country of five million people
so that kind of stratification of wealth right
was exposed not just to be kind of an accident or
you know something that just happened.
It is a direct consequence
of what that report also exposed
which is that we have a tax system that says
those at the top pay an effective tax rate
less than half of that of the average New Zealander
and that goes to the core of what
you're always talking about
which is that those who are at the top
are able to arrange their finances in such a way
cause they have access to accountants and lawyers
and otherwise where wealth just kind of begets wealth
and it accumulates
cause they're able to sit on that pile of treasure
whereas regular
working people are paying income tax as they go
so this is resulting very clearly
in a backsliding of the quality of life
and a massive increase in the cost of living
for regular hard working people
and I think that really contradicts
the egalitarian ideas that we have
not only of other people
projecting onto Aotearoa, New Zealand
but also that we even have of ourselves
right? And I think that
you know, another really important point is that
we are an outlier in the OECD
as the only country in the OECD
that doesn't have a form of wealth tax,
inheritance tax
or even a capital gains tax or stamp duty
None of any of those? None of those
and the political debate is so bloody constrained
it is so frustrating because
whenever we try to talk about fixing those scales right
there's this kind of appeal to like
in some ways
this imported notion of the American dream
or this bizarre reference back to how
you know
in our heads we're egalitarian
whereas very clearly an experience and evidence
we're not.
So you, I mean I think
a lot of British people probably do have that kind of
perception of New Zealand
which is that it's more equal
perhaps that living standards are in some ways better
We've got a lot of nature!
But it's interesting to hear then if you actually...
from what you just described
the tax system of New Zealand is even worse
from an equality perspective
than the tax system of the UK
and my sort of big idea
which I always push here on this channel
is if you don't tax rich people
what will happen is
they will accumulate a lot of money very quickly
and they'll use that to buy the assets
and what you'll start seeing is house prices going up
housing becoming less affordable
So I went on the radio yesterday to like a call in
taking calls
actually on Tom Swarbrick’s show
another Swarbrick, two Swarbrick’s in two days
We're not related as far as I'm aware
And Tom said to me
this is like a quite well known radio host here
he said housing is more affordable in other countries
and I said where and
he didn't say New Zealand
but he said Australia so
you're coming here telling me that the tax
situation in New Zealand is even worse,
what's the housing affordability situation?
It's cooked mate
so on some metrics
we'd have
some of the most unaffordable housing in the world
and part of the reason that right now
house prices are stabilising
despite the current government's best efforts
with giving tax breaks out to landlords
and changing the bright line test by which
you know people end up paying taxes
we are now seeing a stabilising or a slight reduction
but that's despite the government's best efforts
so we've got quite a conservative government
at the moment
some economists have characterised our economy as
more of a housing market with bits tacked on the side
and I think that this kind of is
part and parcel of what we were talking about before
with how this kind of inequality compounds right
people are working so damn hard
so many regular people are working so damn hard
as house prices have escalated before their very eyes
over the last you know
few decades and now
regular people are having to rely on
what's colloquially known as the bank of mum and dad
in order to get into their first house
and that then kind of creates this cultural norm
where nobody wants to create a situation
where it seemed that housing would end up being taxed
so the problem continues to perpetuate
and we end up in this kind of parasitic feedback loop
which is squashing regular
hardworking people. This is really
I mean,
it it reminds me so much of what's happening here
which is you have this situation where
because the rich are not taxed
they're accumulating all this money
and that
all that pushes house prices up in an obvious way
because they can
you are competing with them to buy the houses
you know they don't need to buy them themselves
they can just lend the money for the mortgages
if you have these guys who are sitting on the side
and they're gonna buy anything that has a return of
you know
just over 5% you know
unless the house price is above here
they're gonna buy it
so you have to pay this enormous amount
but then what you
what you get is this kind of perverse reaction
which is
because people know then that unless you own wealth
you're like totally screwed
they then become resistant to the taxation of wealth
and my big challenge here
is to try to communicate to people
if you don't tax the wealth of the very rich
you are the one who's gonna be squeezed out
you're not gonna beat them in that game
one of the reasons why I was keen to have you on is because
here in this country we get a lot of people
leave this country to go to Australia
to go to New Zealand
in this pursuit of better living standards
maybe more equal society maybe more affordable housing
and at the same time as British people say that to me like
like I told you this
I got told this on the radio yesterday
we get people in the comments all the time, Australia
New Zealand, Canada
saying even places like Sweden
oh my God it's so much worse
oh my God
it's so much worse here. So
I was keen to have you on
to perhaps communicate to British people, Europeans
Americans who are watching
this is not a problem that you can run away from
because it is a global problem
it's a worldwide phenomenon
Yeah and again
it's gonna require probably
if we're going to do wealth taxation properly
global coordination. Yeah.
But again you know
as I think you frequently point to
it might be really hard to do
but it is the right thing to do
and it's the only thing, it's the
necessary thing for us to do
if we are to arrest this growing wealth inequality
and this is another thing that I think
it's really important for people to understand
is that poverty doesn't come from nowhere
it is directly caused by this tolerance of
that deep wealth inequality
and this is also where you know
for New Zealanders
and probably around the west of the world
to also understand that
instituting these wealth taxes
is not only about arresting that deeply
and quickly growing wealth inequality
but it's also about
bringing back into the collective pool
the resources necessary
to build the foundations of the society that all of us
bloody live in
which goes to the core of the myth of self made
This is the thing I always,
I don't know if I've emphasized it enough
you know this is not
this is not inequality for inequality’s sake
this is if you allow that inequality to rise
what that also means is you losing your assets!
If the 1% owns 100%
what that means is you own nothing and
and you are being squeezed out
and this is the thing
which I'm constantly trying to think about
how do we communicate
but yeah I was I was keen to have you on talk
to show a little bit that this is not
sometimes people have people ask me
you know how can we do it in the UK alone
and what I always say is, why do it in the UK alone?
If you look at the time when inequality was reduced
after World War 2 it was a big international effort
so I was keen to have you on to show
there are people fighting this fight in other countries
and to be clear we'll get on to this next
you have been supporting wealth taxes
you know I want to have Gabriel Zukman
and Thomas Piketty on, two
of the French economists who've been pushing it
I was over in Norway
talking to Norwegian political parties
there are people all over doing this
but that brings us to the next question
if there are so many people in so many countries
fighting for wealth taxes
and you know, now in the UK
we see the polling
it's overwhelmingly popular with the public
what is stopping us from getting these?
Because you know
you're a politician
you've been in there for a number of years
I'm sure you'll be seeing similar things
in your country
why is it that even centre left political parties
and you can speak
it's also called the Labour Party in New Zealand right?
You can speak for what they've been doing
where is that resistance from
even these traditional centre left coming from and
what do we do and how do we overcome it?
So I think there's a few different things at play
one is very much vested interests
so there are a lot of very wealthy people
who will do absolutely everything that they can
to fan the flames of fear
and to point to division and distraction
and to create division and distraction
amongst regular people so that
you know here
for example it's migrants and our country
I mean definitely
the two more radical right wing parties
are currently falling over themselves
to take credit for a New Zealand values test
that they want to impose on migrants
as well but all of that aside
these very wealthy people own largely
but also influence hugely our media landscape
then I think you know
part and parcel of the unfortunate consequences of this
inequality
is not only that regular people are poorer and poorer
but also that they have less and less time
to engage with the political arena
this has happened simultaneously too
over the last 40 years
very intentional shredding of collective action
of union movements you know
people are living more precarious lives
so the gig economy for example
means that you're less likely to know your coworker
You’re less likely to know your neighbour
because you're less likely to be able to stay in your house
for a long period of time
what that means is that when we see these problems
impacting our day to day lives
we see them as problems with us
not as systemic problems necessarily
so I think
it's also part and parcel of how people perceive
and understand the world. Then it's the media landscape
and the messages that we're getting
about what's actually possible
and feasible. People are intentionally
confused by, you know, again
all of these distractions and all of this division
and that then also bleeds into the vested interests
which influence our politics.
So yeah I think that it really boils down
to put, to flip that on its head
what the solution looks like
is people understanding that
you know, these solutions are not gonna come from vested
interests very clearly
and it's gonna require an understanding that
politics is not as complicated as it's made out
in the same way that
economics is not as complicated as it's made out
you know, I've been in politics now
for the better part of 10 years
politics very simply is just about power
it's about resources
and it's about who gets to make decisions
that saturate and shape our daily lives, right?
That is politics.
Things end up getting complicated
when we throw in all this partisanship
and these political parties
or whatever else
but I think some very clever people
likes of yourself have articulated
you know it is no longer this kind of simplistic
left or right wing thing
it very much is the 1% versus the 99%
and as you've also said before
you know
there's very wealthy people who are looking to protect
their lot or what they perceive is their lot
which I would actually argue
has come at the expense of everybody else
who's working and slogging their guts out.
They are going to
do everything to have regular people believe
that they are not worthy
or they do not deserve a fairer society
and I think this just kind of leads us to the conclusion
why the hell would you let the people
who are currently fleecing you
and laughing their way to the bank
tell you what is possible in politics
It’s cooked
Yeah, I have often used the term in the past
the fire engines are not coming.
What I mean when I say that is
people, definitely people in this country
especially more working class people
have kind of had it drilled into them like
you know, it's not your place to deal with that
like that's the job of the politicians
Yeah, and that also
is I think another big problem, is
you've probably heard the adage,
in relationships
that you get the love that you think that you deserve
so a lot of people
stay in a lot of really shitty relationships right?
I think the same goes
we get the politics that we think that we deserve
and after 40 odd years of politicians
promising one thing and then selling regular
hard working people down the river with
you know, everything that they actually do in reality
you know, this
the implications of that are that
people don't believe that politics
is capable of changing or transforming their lives
so you end up with this really negative feedback loop
whereby people don't get the outcomes that they want
from engaging in politics
so why would they engage?
That lack of engagement results in
a lack of representation on the things that they want
which then results in less action
less engagement
less representation and so on and so forth.
So I've got this kind of strategy right
which I've been calling the Murdoch strategy
which is
you know, what does Rupert Murdoch do?
You don't mind me speaking about Rupert Murdoch?
No go hard.
He has a lot of control over the media
but I think that's slipping a little bit
because of the move towards social media
For those who don't know
this is the guy that owns like tons of like news channels
radio stations, newspapers
controls what the public think
and then because of that he can kind of
decide whether a
political party wins or loses an election
and for that reason
the political parties kind of have to do what he says
right? And then I've seen this move towards social media
which I think has opened a lot of space
because a lot of the traditional
power players in politics
the political parties, the big media stations
including the ones owned by Rupert Murdoch have
not been quick enough to move into that space
and then that's meant that there's all of this kind of
power to take
in terms of influencing what the public believe
what the public understand on social media
and if we move in and take that
then we can educate the public and then
we can be trusted by the public
and then we can do what Murdoch has always done
which is go and have a meeting
with the political leaders
before the elections and say, ‘well
what are you gonna offer me?’ basically
But the stumbling block that I've come to
obviously
I'm not as big or as influential as Rupert Murdoch
but this channel is by the standards of like politics
social media it's massive now right?
And we have a Labour Party
which is polling terribly badly
they look like they're gonna lose
really badly in the next election
This channel is very popular
and very influential with the British public
and yet
this phenomenally unpopular Labour Party are extremely
stubbornly resistant to listening to us
so as somebody who's been within politics
and I guess I know
you've been supportive of wealth taxes for a long time
maybe you've had similar experiences yourself
have you got any advice for
like what can we do
what should we do? Should we change our strategy
in trying to influence Labour
should we forget about Labour
and just go straight for the public
have you got any advice about what we should do?
Oh mate
if I had advice to give you
we would have sorted out all our problems right?
But I think that this is
kind of exposing the fact that
I've been here now for a few
days and I've been meeting with some phenomenal people
likes of yourself and you know
some of your local politicians and economists and
you know I'm gonna meet with some more
the likes of Piketty and Zucman
and what I am learning
is that nobody has solved this problem
there is no clear answer
which leads me to the conclusion
that we have to get our bloody hands dirty
you know, I am part of so many conversations
with so many smart people
who paralyze themselves by falling over
needing to be right or having all of the perfect plans
before we just start moving on it
and I guess in the most simplistic way
there's kind of two broad spheres
that we can bring about change in
and they're very interconnected
the boundaries between them are really porous and open
and that's kind of
structure, so the structures of society are legislation
regulation, funding
taxation systems, the incentives, subsidies
trade agreements, treaties
procurement processes, contracts
etcetera. That's like the blueprint or the coat hooks
or the social contract
as it's written down in black and white
but that stuff gets its legitimacy from
and can be delegitimised by culture
and this is really important
cause culture here
I'm defining from a design thinking perspective
which is about a shared set of values
and when you understand our culture
as a shared set of values
you can come to understand
how we create this thing called society
which we all live in
with people from all of these different backgrounds
who come together to prioritize
whether it be implicitly not talking about it
or explicitly
intentionally working through that democratically
hopefully what those values actually are
so that's kind of the glue that binds society together
right? And if you think about the different leverage points
for changing culture, so therefore
creating the environment conducive to structural change
to changing politics, to changing our laws
to changing our tax system
it's things like media
which as you've just talked about
is being massively influenced
or undercut now by the social media landscape
it's things like education
which is really important
but it takes a really bloody long time
especially
if you do that through the compulsory education system
but more fundamentally it's about community building
I think
and this is where we have to be honest with ourselves
about the really hard graft
that is obviously
the likes of petition and protest
but more than that, conversation
and regular people feeling confident
and capable enough to talk to each other
about what these problems are.
Understand that they are shared problems
they're not our own individual problems
they're systemic problems
and then work together
organising to try and change that.
So I guess you know
that's a roundabout way of providing the context
to answer your question which is that
if we are to get the critical mass necessary
to make this change politically
then we need more regular
people who know that they are just as bloody entitled
to have an opinion on something
to approach their politician
and to make a political impact
as the Rupert Murdochs of this world.
Yeah this is pretty much in line with
with what I've been saying
which is I think that
I think that there's a there's a lack of compelling
cohesive popular political messages at the moment
I think we've moved into a space of kind of broad
lack of faith of politicians
but I think that provides a lot of opportunity for like,
individuals acting as amplifiers of a message
so like, the popularity of this channel
you know, we've never spent a penny on advertising
it's word of mouth right?
And I keep saying, you know
if everybody convinces one person
then you get everybody and
I do think there's huge space to grow that
through conversations. But on that topic
I can't talk to you today
without bringing up the subject of rising anti
immigrant sentiment
the increased popularity of the far right
There was a huge rally here this weekend
this weekend just gone, by the far right here in London
I think they have really in a sense
done a good job of spreading a message
through social media totally through people
through communities
and they tapped into real anger
Yeah, and when you talk about conversation
I worry a little bit
we're having... it's
making conversations more difficult
because
I feel that this country is moving a little bit more
towards the
kind of
very divided society that you see more so in the US
where you're either on one side or the other side
and people can't really talk
What's the situation like in New Zealand
do you have a rising far right
is it similar, are similar things happening
and what can we do about it?
I mean I don't think
that would be remiss of me to say that
we've got
the most right wing government that we've had
in a generation and they are very intentionally
shredding the social safety net
so they put a hiring freeze in our healthcare system
which is you know
resulting in
people waiting hours and hours in emergency departments
our education system is
falling apart at the seams
and again none of this is for lack of the amazing
people in those systems really trying
but they're burning out
and many of them are then looking offshore
for better opportunities
better quality of life for them and their family
for lower cost of living
and all of those kinds of things
and this is also why I think
it's important that we're talking
and understanding that this is a global phenomenon
right?
So while people might move to try and escape these issues
domestically they'll chase them because
you know, the billionaires are coming and
you know Peter Thiel
has citizenship in my country
and is building a bunker
it’s maddening. So I guess again
this is where we need to understand that
in terms of the political analysis
and this polarisation, tepid centrism
that is, you know
centre left parties have been bumbling along
and not meaningfully
addressing the material conditions
of regular working people
for the last 40 years. People are not stupid
they understand
that their day to day lives are deteriorating
that things are getting harder
that they are working longer
and they are angry about that
and they need somewhere to put that anger
and the kind of major proposition from
supposedly left wing parties
or centre left wing parties over the last 40 years
and particularly the last 10 or so years
has effectively been tokenism
has been going well
we're gonna put one person from a structurally
marginalized community into a position of power
not change the power structures
not deal with any of the fundamental issues in society
but we're just gonna
kind of put a gloss on hyper capitalism
and this deeply entrenched inequality
and you know
I think that in turn has meant that
there is a space for the far right to kind of enter
and go, OK
well it's that person who's been placed into that
supposed position of power
this like historically structurally marginalized person
well they're the problem
you know
it's the gays or the migrants or whatever
and this is where I think
to kind of come back down to earth
and to think about how we do
tangibly and realistically
that organizing
that I was alluding to in those conversations
you know, I kinda come back to this really basic point
one of the first things I wanted to do
when I became co leader of the greens
in Aotearoa was to go and talk to the coal miners
because so frequently, obviously
green movements are pitched against working people
particularly working class people in
you know, these industrial areas
so I don't have beef with coal miners
in fact I want them to live good lives
but we obviously need to decarbonize our economy
if we're gonna have a future and a livable planet
so went down to the West coast of the South Island and
I love
nothing more than a challenge of talking to people
who think that they'll hate me
and you know
after talking through some of those initial assumptions
about who I was and what I was there to do
we kind of
then immediately get down to the brass tacks of it
and it's crazy. At the end of the day
all these guys wanted was a decent income
to be able to stay in their community
and feel a sense of pride in what they do
Those are things we can agree on
that is the broadest base unifying thing
that brings together people in my country
people in your country regular people across the world
it's the foundations of Maslow's hierarchy of needs
that is where we will find our solidarity
that is the stuff that we can agree on
so I think that you know
when it comes to
kind of trying to reach across the aisle
and talk to these people
who are in these incredibly angry spaces
and are being co opted
and manipulated by the far right
obviously that's not a role for
particularly
those who are subjected to all of that hatred
but I do think
those of us who have a familiar or family connection
if we can just kind of spend the time and ask people
why they think the way that they do
and how they kind of came to those conclusions
you know people will come to unpack
and when they are talking about
why they think the way that they do
they will start to acknowledge themselves
if they're genuinely being listened to
that maybe there are some gaps in their logic.
I think I think often there's less
between
some of the people who are supporting what we do
who want a wealth tax
and some of the people going on these marches
then you might think and I've seen some guys
there's a guy
there's a youtuber here called Jimmy the giant
I like and I think it was on
he tweeted it, but I think it was on Politics Joe
they went and they spoke to some of these guys
a lot of these guys want wealth taxes
and I think
the situation we have here is
you know everybody hates the Conservatives
it's understandable people are starting to hate Labour
and that's understandable as well
and then Reform our sort of new right
far right party, they
kind of win by being the only voice left in the room
because the left hasn't really been able to
establish a presence in social media
which is where these people are
or in the mainstream media
and I actually think there's a massive space
for a fourth voice
which doesn't have to be on the left, that
that really does anything
that centers living standards, economics
inequality, taxation
which is what I'm trying to be
it sounds like you're trying to do a similar thing here
I should ask you why you're here
you're obviously co leader of the New Zealand Greens
we’ve got a new leader of our British Greens
and he's Zack Polanski for those who don't know
He's great. He seems to be looking to do a similar thing
which is focus a lot on the economy
focus on inequality, be there on social media
be loud, make a voice
any opinions on him?
Oh yeah
no Zack and I met a few days ago and he's awesome
I think that he has an incredible opportunity to yeah
work with people, to have them realise
that all of these problems are so deeply interconnected
right? I mean
it's really funny because our name is Green
and our colour is green
of course we care about the environment
we care about saving the bats and our native species
and all of those other things
but we also care about all life on earth
you know, and it's really
bloody hard to get people to care about the end of the planet
or the end of life on earth as we know it
if they can't put food on the table
for the end of the week. So
any program that is focused on centering
kind of our ecological needs
or our planetary limits needs to bear in mind that
in order to change public policy
to get to that place we need to ensure that everybody
has their basic needs met
so I think it really is that simple
it's about understanding
the same system that is exploiting our planet
is exploiting and exhausting people
and that's where we kind of
come back down to this really basic proposition that
what the hell are we all working so hard for
if not
to have a society that caters to our basic needs
I mean I hope it works
I hope it works
I sometimes feel that I'm sort of
the only guy pushing progressive voice on social media
and I know I'm not
I know there's lots of other people doing it
but I look at what Zack's doing
focusing on inequality, focusing on taxation
focusing on social media
and I hope it works cause
then I could go on holiday and feel like someone else
is doing it
He's got a really clear,
he's got a really clear message
and I mean this is kind of always my call to action
to anybody who, you know
is maybe sitting there at home and going
she doesn't know what the hell she's talking about
well get involved!
Then get your hands dirty
I will take critique from anybody
who is willing to bloody try
You know if enough of us try
then we'll win, I always say that
but let's not, let's not fight in the background right
let's bloody do it
I see too many circular firing squads
but I know you gotta go soon
before you go
I get criticized a lot for being quite pessimistic
because I am quite pessimistic
and given you know
the mood in this country at the moment
is quite pessimistic
I try my best to finish on messages of hope
so I would like to ask you before we finish
do you feel hopeful for the future
is there something you feel hopeful about
what gives you hope?
I feel incredibly hopeful about the future
I wouldn't be able to do what I do if I don't
you know I travel around my country
and obviously been on the other side of the planet
for the first time in several years
And whenever I feel a sense of pessimism or despondency
or whatever you wanna characterize it as
just look for the helpers
and you will find abundant people
who are doing their best day in and day out
in ways big and small to make the world a better place
and if we start connecting the dots
between all of those actions
and those practices of people living their values
and doing the right thing
and we scale that up
then we've kind of changed the world overnight
you know, so yeah
I feel an incredible sense of hope
and I think that it's about people realizing
and this is my kind of classic
go to
that inspiration
is not a reason to put somebody on a pedestal
and go
that person's gonna solve all of the world's problems
clearly they're not you know
if you look at
all of the amazing things that human beings
have been able to achieve
in the arc of history, civil rights
gay rights, women's rights
whatever, it has always been
regular people working together at scale
to change our politics up against some of the most
heinous and difficult barriers
that you can possibly conceptualize
and imagine. So inspiration is a mirror
it is you seeing in somebody else
actually something that you admire about yourself
and that is an invitation to participate
and to be part of something bigger
and the kind of co benefit
or the other really awesome thing about that is
our mental health will be so much better for it.
I hope so, I hope so
I think we can make it better
I think we can and I think that we have to
and I think that in the process of trying
we need to have some fucking fun
I'll try my best, that's never been a specialty of mine
but thank you very much
first ever politician on the channel
thanks for coming all the way over and yeah
good luck
nice to meet you, Chlöe Swarbrick. You too mate